hey there,
stop scrolling for a second.
I have a question for you,
but you know what the minimum age for eligibility is
in the European Parliament in Italy?
I give you 3s to answer,
still nothing.
well,
know that he is 25 years old.
we are the only country in the European Union
to have the minimum age so High,
along with Greece.
lack of happiness
of young people in the European Parliament
can only result in a further departure
by them - From politics.
as a strong supporter
of equality in democratic exercise in Italy
I think this is unacceptable.
it is important to bring ideas and voice to Europe
of young Italians.
that's why the campaign is born
You power you.
in a country that is steadily declining in population and that
too often marginalizes its own
young people by decisions
important to their future,
duxo's youth power u campaign launched
Aims to change things
Raising the threshold of the passive electorate to 18 years of age
Instead of the current 25.
so if you want to make a difference
sign the petition as well.
find everything about the campaign,
how to sign in the link here.